what's it been like to you
watching this play out on social media
like i've seen a lot of misinformation
i've seen videos like look how awesome
this video is it's from 2014. the
associate npr had a thread maybe i'll
try and find and share it was like
here's all the things that have been
going viral that are completely false i
just think it's disastrous for our
mental health that we're watching a war
play on social media a real a real like
large-scale war yeah and i think for
young people in particular like it
really shakes your foundation because
you think to yourself hey i live in a
city um oh look i'm seeing these people
like fleeing for their lives i'm seeing
apartment buildings getting shelled i'm
seeing
uh
people making their own tanks just roll
into town i'm seeing civilians russia
surround the capital city whatever it is
yeah yeah yeah it's i i think it's just
terrible for everyone's
mental health and well-being on a level
that i can't recall
um
you know like i i'm imagine i'm
remembering when folks were watching tv
in the 90s during the gulf war in gulf
war 2. social media was not to this
level and you didn't have folks just
broadcasting what was going on in those
locations
[Music]
[Music]
this week on ford
russia's invasion of ukraine how it
could play out best case scenarios
economic and political
impact here in the u.s this week on
forward
[Music]
welcome back
welcome back it is uh
it it's been a tough time i think for
most everyone because i don't know about
you zack but like every day you wake up
and then you go to your phone and be
like what is going on in ukraine
watching this play out on social media
is
what fascinating is a word i'm going to
use but not in a good way like you know
it's engrossing yeah
negative a lot of negative energy
it's debilitating
thoughts on what's what you're seeing
what you're not seeing what you're
wading through every day what are your
high-level thoughts andrew i'm really
heartened by the relatively unified
response out of the west
uh these stories of for example poland
uh giving fighter jets to ukrainian
pilots who essentially get in the plane
and then just are able to take off
because
they're
russian-made models that ukrainian
pilots are more or less familiar with
that image really struck me where like
you're bringing fighter planes and
they're just like able to take off in
them and go fight
uh the
appeal by
president zielenski saying hey anyone
who wants to come fight with us will
give you weapons like him like legit
hunkering down and
bearing arms and fighting yeah
it's been one of the most inspirational
things that uh i can remember um so
zolensky
is by background a tv actor
uh who played a president in a
sitcom a bit of a comedy right yeah it
would be the equivalent of
i'm going to say tom hanks becoming
president here in the u.s i was going to
say julie right
what's her name julie driving louis
dreyfus louis dreyfus where she
literally played the president well she
played vice president i think did she
eventually get vp in the series anyway
she was mainly a vp and then became
president for like a half minute yes i'm
not sure if tom hanks played a president
but i'm thinking about tom hanks in the
80s when he was a comic actor
kevin spacey maybe and then he went
serious you could say uh kevin kline
from dave
oh yeah anybody has to be a comedy and
like honestly it's a really good
strategy because americans one of the
hardest parts of getting elected
president and we dealt with this was
can americans visualize and see you as
their president well this is one of the
darker elements of contemporary life
but there is so much performance
involved in being a political figure at
this point yeah where if you can get in
front of a tv camera and give a
compelling speech off of a teleprompter
that actually is a a very important
skill it's a qualifier yeah you don't
qualify for the job yes
and so would a world-class actor be
excellent at that 100 yes which is funny
because some of the best operators in
the world today let's call it i mean you
i'm gonna use the word term best i'm
gonna say top earners and entrepreneurs
let's call it zuckerbergs or elon musk
or that sort of thing would probably be
horrible
in those environments yeah sure they're
not performers right in that way um and
that's
you know whole we could actually we have
had a whole podcast on this in some ways
anyway
zolensky was a comedian president and is
now the real president and that's now
the real president but there were a
couple of ways it could go and the way
it went is that zielinski
has hunkered down and said this is my
country i don't need a ride i need
ammunition
uh let's greet them with molotov
cocktails like the whole thing has been
extraordinary
and has highlighted for i think he has
legitimately shamed
the west into helping
because he's willing to sacrifice so
much his uh country men and women are
sacrificing so much you're like okay
like we have to get with the program and
help this
country help this man
it's been one of
uh the most singular things i've ever
recalled
and i think he single-handedly turned
the world sentiment in a particular
direction yes um so the sanctions have
gone up and up and up
uh to the point where it feels like
every day this conflict goes on is a
punishing day
for
the russian economy for putin the ruble
has crashed against the dollar
apparently about half of their foreign
reserves are off limits to them
uh there's at least one russian bank
that's reported to be on the verge of
failure
so uh it's
uh it's clear to me it's clear to me
that
uh that putin expected it to be easier
and faster i think he expected crimea
the sequel
and it is not uh and so now every day
seems to matter
so heartened by the western unified
response heartened by the cost it's
uh
it's imposing on russia the pressure the
single biggest variable now is whether
putin's a rational actor
and there is increasing concern that
he's not as rational as you'd hope
he's 70 years old he's been in power for
two decades plus
uh he's ruled with a an iron fist he
doesn't have a whole lot of
checks and balances going on he's
surrounded by folks who are probably
deathly afraid of him
and so as this conflict escalates the
major question is
as the cost goes up will his
better instincts prevail where he says
look that this cost is terrible in terms
of
uh the economy
um
lives of russian soldiers things that
matters to him um and does he say okay
we'll take the eastern separatist parts
of ukraine
call it victory
withdraw
and then go back and hope that the west
uh
rescinds these sanctions and we go back
to something approaching normality or
does he say okay
we're going to elevate this uh to a
point where there's no restraint in
terms of
uh bombarding civilian buildings and
cities uh in
ukraine because you know that there is a
level of restraint um unfortunately it
was reported that they used at least one
of these vacuum bombs that causes
massive harm but you know that russia
has the whole spectrum
all the way up to nuclear weapons it's
remarkable to me how much hinges upon
the mentality and rationality of one
human
but here we are
it's 2022 and just about everything you
do is made just for you with the
possible exception for most people still
of your coffee despite the fact that you
really have strong feelings about your
coffee
let's change that right now go to trade
coffee and take a coffee quiz
to get started they will send you your
first bag made just for you and if you
don't love it they will replace it for
free
it's a coffee subscription with no
hassle
change your frequency you can modify it
or even cancel at any time and for our
listeners right now
trade coffee is offering you a total of
twenty dollars off your first three bags
when you go to drinktrade.com
yang to get started take their quiz at
drinktrade.com
yang and start your journey to your
perfect cup of coffee that's
drinktrade.com
yang for 20 bucks off your first three
bags you'll be glad you did
[Music]
right now like where we are today is
obviously russia has invaded ukraine
it's not going fast let's put it that
way like the miss like the information
is flying sideways we have no idea what
putin's actual mentality and timeline
was but it seems to be slow and the west
this has united the west um particularly
the eu um so you're seeing a couple
things so the eu
accepted ukraine's application to join
which they hadn't before which is really
an economic thing and not a military
thing but they're giving them 500
million dollars in aid for their
military i'm quoting a politico
instagram post which is actually pretty
good the eu will be shutting down
airspace
it's airspace to russian flights and
putting a ban on their kremlin media
machine
germany is halting uh their
nordstrom 2 energy pipeline with moscow
so they're getting crushed on that type
of stuff the us is hunting down
any rich russian in the u.s
it appears they're going after the quote
was they're going after
this is from the white house or by
administration senior official we're
going after their yachts their luxury
apartments their money and their ability
to send their kids to fancy schools in
the west which is probably a very
interesting or effective tactic
potentially
the
they're targeting putin's personal
assets in the u.s and in europe
which is apparently billions in wealth
and
one well my favorite one was uh
bp
was just getting rid of its twenty
percent stake in rosneft rosneft i'm not
sure how it's pronounced but it's a
state-controlled oil producer which is
billions of dollars they're just [ __ ]
you putin [ __ ] everything
so the strategy here is
russia goes in with bombs and guns and
planes and trying to take this over
ukraine says this is our home [ __ ] you
and the international community is now
just trying to squeeze them out sanction
wise do you think putin gives a [ __ ]
about sanctions yeah i think he does
really you know i think he expected to
be sanctioned but i think he's being
surprised by the severity and unanimity
and breadth of these sanctions
and i think it was easier for him before
the fact to say okay they'll sanction me
it won't be so bad
because we have kind of sanctioned him
before right and i've been far weaker
but it's it seems
the harm and the pain
are deeper and more severe than
um
i believe that he saw coming and
uh he may or may not care about the
fortunes of other oligarchs uh who've
lost i think i saw a number where
they've lost you know 40 billion 80
billion like whatever the number is yeah
uh collectively a lot of these russian
companies are globally listed yeah and
they're yeah they're getting crushed
so uh to the extent that that he has a
circle around him um that circle is
saying to him hey
uh this
is painful and please make it stop
now it could be that he doesn't actually
hear those figures or care
but i don't think he anticipated the
severity and one big sign of that is
that he saber-rattled uh
the other day where he said hey these
sanctions are um uh
above and beyond and i will threaten you
know essentially nuclear deterrence
which by the way makes zero sense it's
like you cut off my banking system and i
nuked you like
and i'm happy to say that no one took it
seriously
um but it it showed that these were not
things that he anticipated and was
taking in stride i mean look we i think
we're all we are all shocked by the
sanctions and i think the european union
was very shocked that they were able to
get everybody together and that sort of
um get aligned write this uh like this
second this brings me a second question
though do you think putin is a rational
actor
yeah
no you hope so but there are some
indications that he may might not be
uh as lucid as you'd hope um i don't see
any real evidence that he is
like the whole thing is irrational it's
a hitler type mentality it appears this
whole thing strikes one as deeply
irrational yeah i think that there's
been a wholesale miscalculation on his
part around the nature
of the
welcome or resistance he'd receive in
ukraine i think he talked himself into
the fact that people
would
maybe not be happy to see him but
certainly wouldn't be fighting tooth and
nail right and that they'd be able to
take uh the capital relatively quickly
um and so that that's just you know you
delude yourself so i i think he fooled
himself on on that score and now that
he's getting all this evidence that it's
not working out that way the question is
does he double down or does he rethink
and right and uh pull back so this is
where i want to go i think we're have
fun with this so we
ran for president you wrote your book
and a lot of stuff you even with forward
party a lot of stuff you're doing
it's really can tie back to one main
prince one of the main principles but a
main principle that everything we do
revolves around the almighty dollar
right we talk about that but it
and that has been
it's literally been gone to
the vast majority definitely the west
but most the most of the world and most
people
and uh my interesting thought i'm
curious what you think is that it feels
like we actually hit its limit in that
we talk about bp pulling out of a deal
they're gonna lose billions of dollars
right now the stock market like you're
not invested you're not touching russia
you're if you're a hedge fund you're not
touching russian companies if you can
get out of your investments right you're
dealing with backlash and supporting
that you go visa
is out of russia like apple pay all of
that right so
it seems like this almighty dollar has a
point until you hit good or evil and
bill ackman hedge fund guy
he likes you if i recall um
smart guy he put out a massive twitter
thread saying basically calling joe
biden to go to war
and send troops there and which you know
he doesn't have kids
at military age he's not going to put up
ourselves i don't love that but he did
make some good points and one of the
points he made was that this was
this is not a money war this is a just
war this is a good verse evil war
do you agree with that and is that
changing our like almighty dollar
calculus so first the biggest indication
of the almighty dollar ruling your
institutions i would argue is
china's relationship with hollywood with
the nba where no one can speak ill of
china uh you remember that john cena oh
yeah man apology and whatnot it's like
china has
uh you know such a huge market and it's
such a big
revenue driver for
uh some of our biggest entertainment
right and that's about money not morals
i mean it is about morals but no no it's
about money i mean i think everyone
knows that it's just like look big
market sure so let's
sand down any uh any criticism like we
don't mind your human rights violations
as long as you stay in your borders in
your own bubble but as soon as you start
[ __ ] with others
on a massive scale we might i don't know
like outside your borders so so there so
there is this market uh driven mentality
and i i think one of the reasons why
russia's invasion of ukraine is setting
everyone off uh is because it's so
highly irrational and value destructive
uh
and so you're taking that value
destruction and you're having russia
internalize it
so
uh uh the fact that there is that this
my uh instinct generally
is that the u.s should be doing
everything in its power to help ukraine
uh
in part because of the rationale that
this is an entirely unjustified uh
irrational war from a superpower yeah
and and that if if you are the united
states
uh this is the clearest moral imperative
i have seen
uh in terms of having a democracy
uh getting
attacked by a hostile aggressor
um
in a way that's
uh that's really stark and this is from
a guy who you know thinks military
interventions are the absolute last
resort
um but i think that there is a lot of
compelling reason
for us to see this as something
that's core
to
uh world order that benefits the united
states of america
you know if you had to put like a value
on it it's kind of incalculable
you know that that world order
disintegrates
then a lot of stuff goes away
uh and the world like it or not kind of
relies upon the u.s to maintain that
order it's an order that the us is one
of the biggest beneficiaries of yep a
lot of people benefit from it uh and if
you have something like this invasion go
unchecked now uh right now you could
very
you know you could very clearly argue
it's like look the us is doing a lot of
stuff
to put pressure uh on russia
but
the entire time i felt like
russia was capitalizing on american
disunity and weakness
i'm
very glad that it seems to have rallied
uh the west uh and revitalized nato in
terms of global unity um it has been
remarkable and maybe since 9 11 but one
of the interesting things is that i
think most all americans now are like we
stand with ukraine russia the ones i
follow a bunch of far right and far left
accounts and there's some on the far
right that are thinking
russia is not the only bad guy well this
is such a lame
yeah um the the big question is whether
there would be appetite for american
military
action or intervention and the polling
i've seen on that is
uh that the majority of americans think
that sanctions are appropriate but uh
sending troops is not it appears we have
not gone and sent troops because he's
got nuclear bombs
and we don't think he's rational so
sending troops
would be an act of war
against russia
and they could justify their people
that's almost coming after them and then
once you start one nuclear bomb it's
it's a domino effect and it's awful do
you agree with that are we
is that our big i'm assuming that's our
biggest deterrents from trying to fight
the guy
well one of the the things that occurred
to me and
alexander bidman made this case uh is
that before the fact if you let's say
did have a handful of american
troops in ukraine then that's like a
deterrent the other direction is like
look if you attack
ukraine which by the way before putin
attacked ukraine most people thought
there's no way he's crazy enough to
right actually invade so if you had
american troops there and american
troops get killed against us there's an
act of war against us and by the way
that's like a pretty
effective deterrent in my mind and then
you know
um so uh so that that was uh to me like
you know a step that maybe could have
been considered uh before the fact that
that's kind of revisionist now
so now
it seems like we'd be escalating things
like you you want to not be necessarily
the the person who's responsible for you
know the escalation and now would be
perceived as an escalation if you went
that direction whereas before you know
like i mean russia obviously is
been the clear aggressor um so
at this point
um i think that
uh
trying to max out
non-military punishments
um seems like the way to go
you know i think seizing assets of
oligarchs and uh putin
totally appropriate right
what seems i guess what breaks my heart
and i know this is this is like the
emotional
side of this at least for me
is that ukraine's getting
like even if though they're holding the
fort in a way
and doing way better than expected
they're getting bum rush right they're
getting they're getting blown out of
like their whole way of life is ruined
um or you know
being sent back centuries um
they've got military presence in their
streets there's violence people are
dying right
and we the world
are just watching now we're doing things
right we are
making it harder for russia to do what
they're doing we're
taking away their resources to make it
more challenging or impossible to do
certain things but we're not actually
taking up [ __ ] sword or gun
and fighting and i
i hate that you know what i'm saying
like it's a bad feeling it feels awful
it feels awful and it's because we're
scared i think the answer is only to me
that we're scared of them like we're
scared that they
nuke somebody without rationality and we
can't stop it um
which
isn't something we maybe never really
talked to thought about before when it
came to this mutually assured
destruction from nuclear so it's like oh
yeah like well
i won't i can't stop you from doing like
this level of bad stuff because
you could do that level bad so i'm going
to let it go to a certain point you know
what's funny is like i initially thought
that the us could intervene uh through
conventional means yeah and and
essentially just like look no one's
crazy enough to nuke anyone right so you
know even if like you know i send some
planes and send some troops and send
some support like you know that's not
nuke worthy like you know
like where
you know uh so uh like i i i imagine
that there might be a level of restraint
um on both sides because especially you
know the us and russia then
putin's not a rational actor so we don't
really know
you know what i love to do that you love
to do
sleep
yup you do it eight hours a day if
you're lucky and yet you might not have
invested properly in that mattress that
you freaking snuggle up to
every single night why not have a
mattress that's made just for you it's
personalized to the way you want to
sleep your body type your sleep
preferences everyone is unique do you
like it hot do you like it cool do you
like it soft do you like it firm heck i
don't want to know but you know who does
want to know
helix helix sleep is going to send you
the best mattress of your life they were
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gqn wired
magazine just go to helixsleep.com
yang and take their two minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life with a
10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights and risk-free imagine
trying something for 99 nights and
sending it back but they know you're not
going to send it back because they have
that much confidence in their mattress
and so do i helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com yang best mattress around
helixsleep.com
[Music]
what's it been like to you
watching this play out on social media
like i've seen a lot of misinformation
i've seen videos like look how awesome
this video is it's from 2014. the
associate npr had a thread maybe i'll
try and find and share it was like
here's all the things that have been
going viral that are completely false i
just think disastrous for our mental
health that we're watching the war play
on social media a real
a real like large-scale war yeah and i
think for young people in particular
like it really shakes your foundation
because you think to yourself hey i live
in a city um oh look i'm seeing these
people like fleeing for their lives i'm
seeing apartment buildings getting
shelled i'm seeing
uh
people making their own i'm seeing tanks
just roll into town i'm seeing civilians
russia surround the capital city
whatever it is yeah yeah yeah i i think
it's just terrible for everyone's
mental health and well-being on a level
that i can't recall
um
you know like i i'm imagine i'm
remembering when folks were watching tv
in the 90s during the gulf war and gulf
war too social media was not to this
level and you didn't have folks just
broadcasting what was going on in those
locations you're like well world war ii
right was the first i mean maybe you
could argue you could argue world war
one but world war ii that fundamental
evil you know i'm saying yeah yeah and
but it was still distant you're reading
about it via newspapers right here
you're what you're witnessing you're
[ __ ] living that evil right yes uh
i'm on social media and one of the
things i don't do
is i don't
amplify
um these videos that make you feel very
intensely
uh one thing or another you know like
999 times out of a thousand i'm like i'm
not going to i'm going to
yeah because
uh you know it just makes you feel
um
very very strongly one emotion whether
it's horror or
uh anger or fear or fear society or even
some of the positives where it's like
look at this there's some beautiful
stories like look at this moral actor
look at this like like you know like i'm
so this is something that i you know
it's kind of tough for me to say but i
feel like even the positive stuff
like it's kind of
um
like reinforcing
a
reactivity that i don't think is very
positive or healthy
where it's like pretty much if you home
in on this beacon of
um
like horrific or uplifting behavior
um then you get whipsawed in various
ways like like if if i'm magnifying
something like super
um courageous and uplifting then i feel
like that person's then just going to go
from there to another video that's
horrifying and then just wound up you
know having their uh emotional pendulum
just get like swing back ukraine
algorithm yeah yeah and and so it's it's
not productive or healthy i mean like a
lot of the way i live is to think okay
what can i do about this i don't know
how often we talk about the podcast but
between us we talk a lot about
performative empathy it's one thing we
struggle with as
let's call former democrats or folks
with a conscience and empathy where it's
like there are things i can say that'll
make you feel good and make me feel good
and make me feel like i'm on the right
team or doing the right like you know
the things that are just or moral right
but then there's stuff that needs to be
done which is more gritty and
nitty-gritty but like it's it's like
it's solving the root causes of of
police brutality and what we all went
through with george floyd like
you could say the right things you put
the black lives matter flag up you can
do all the things but then if you
actually want to solve that problem it's
complicated it's nuanced that and so in
this situation you have a bunch of
people be like stand with ukraine here's
a wholesome video donate to save the
children or xyz but at the end of the
day there's very little we can actually
do because unless you're going to pick
up a gun get to ukraine and fight
or unless you're a government official
that can control money resources food
xyz and russia as well there's there's
nothing you can
the money's not really helping as much
as we we hope i'm sure it's like on the
margins sure but it's not a money issue
realistically um do you agree with that
like the performance maybe it's you
think it's waking people up on
putting the ukraine flagging your
twitter bio isn't really particularly
helping anything or well i think sending
money is always helpful i mean money's
real it's real but it's humanitarian
things um you know the the uh expressing
solidarian alignment um you know like
um
[Music]
in this instance probably you know
mildly i guess better than nothing i
guess like yeah
you know you do want to distinguish
though between
expression and action uh as uh you've
all have been
put it yeah uh and so
on this one there really is one human
being at the center of it all and his
name is one [ __ ] guy who has vladimir
putin and
you know like if
yeah if there's a way that you could
somehow influence what's going on in
that state of mind then you know
um for it other than that try and help
people at the margins now but i i do
think that
that there's something
really really
uh
damaging
about folks having
these
real-life
uh
conflicts and images playing out in
social media and the way that they are
and
you know unfortunately i think this is
going to be a pattern where one of the
things i put in the war on normal people
is that if you had a trucker convoy was
my example and then you had conflict
break around uh break out around that
trucker convoy then you'd have these
images
go out to millions and millions of
people
of some isolated atrocity and then it
would end up inflaming folks in a
particular way
and that's accurate you know
so let's say that the ukraine conflict
goes on for
months which i guess is at least
conceivable mm-hmm uh you know like now
that there's going to be a recurring
issue as conflicts happen as uh
tragedies happen
uh you know it's something that
i think is terrible for the next
generation's mental health truly yeah
i'm grateful i came of age in the time
before social media
so i
have now written a book and it's coming
out soon we'll talk about it a different
time but on
the attention economy in our like how
that's changing everything and
there's just so many things that
dominate our discourse for a hot moment
and then it's as if they never happened
right um and you if you look back at
your year or the past month or six
months like holy cow i was so pissed
about that and then it's just out of out
of sight out of mind it's like we just
go go to different topics and
this one
i imagine because it's not
at home to us it's not hitting home to
me what's going to happen is it'll stop
raiding well on tv and we'll move on to
something else the next trucker convoy
and i think that that convoy is actually
moving through texas the one that was in
canada i think uh
the election will happen i'm biden doing
something got the state of the union uh
that just happened we haven't heard it
yet but it's we're recording this on
tuesday but um which is it's the night
for us um
do you think we lose
i guess maybe you're saying no one knows
but we probably started to lose
attention on this and that um i i think
your current ukraine remains front and
center while the conflict is ongoing and
i do think that
uh god willing it gets resolved in a
matter of days or weeks and not months
what does resolution look like putin is
like you said before putin declares a
[ __ ] victory
the best case scenario is putin declares
victory and goes back and says hey we
got we made it safe for the separatist
areas of of ukraine
problem solved uh
you know like uh business as usual
that's our best case scenario and worst
is nuclear war right
the worst case is nuclear
conflicts terrifying everybody though i
will say it would be
entirely irrational for his argument to
be russian ukraine are one people we are
the same
and i'm going to new york i'm a nuke
like that makes zero sense
uh you know one of the things i found
encouraging is that
russians are standing up the russian
people don't like this there's a very
unpopular war
everywhere including russia
yeah last i saw they'd arrested um you
know several thousand people for
protesting so imagine you live under an
authoritarian regime your
leader is a former kgb strong man
and you decide to protest the war i mean
you pretty much know you're gonna
get arrested and go to jail this is not
like a you know right to assemble
situation no it's not um
and so you have
thousands of people willing to risk
themselves that way
um which means in my mind you have
millions of people who feel the same way
there are a number of prominent figures
in russian society who are like hey this
is this war is not nothing that any of
us wants um it really is one malignant
person
leading
uh them
to a war that most people thought was
well out of the bounds of possibility i
was just reading that the u.s was going
around to folks being like hey fyi we
think that russia may invade ukraine and
everyone didn't believe it
we're only eight months away from the
midterms what do you think the political
consequences are here
in the united states democrats
republicans i have some thoughts too
have some fun i should share but i want
yours at first
i think that this is
uh
an opportunity for biden to refocus his
presidency on leadership and competence
and morality
and
it sharpens the contrast between him and
the republicans in various ways now most
republicans
are anti-putin
supportive of
these measures
there are some marginal voices that
aren't but you know like that they're
pretty much out there
um so it's not like there's a sharp
contrast whereby it wants to do one
thing republicans want to do something
else um but i i think that
this conflict and biden's leadership uh
probably at least mildly maybe
significantly helpful
for his administration and democrats so
there's a poll that was circled around a
lot was that
most people
both democrats and republicans believe
that this situation in russia would not
have happened if trump was president and
that putin was
essentially implying which i think was
like maybe some people believe this that
putin's less scared than buying than he
would be of trump
in doing this
felt that there was
less consequences if he acted i
think if biden
i don't know if i know trump just voiced
approval for this entire course of
action so he does yes but like he
wouldn't have been yeah
it might have been the reverse where
putin's like hey trump's going to be
cool with this so let me do this thing
and then trump as president is like hey
uh let russia do russia
perhaps like i'm not disagreeing i'm not
even trying to speculate what trump
would be doing it was just that polls
like
would this have happened if trump was
president so as you tell i'm of the mind
that this totally happens oh yeah i
think it would too i don't think that's
an accurate but i think that the this is
like the sentiment and that's the
message that
fox news and the republican party has
been going with like our weak
president and country and
lack of strategy and strength
at home is hurting us abroad and putin
thinks he can do whatever we want
without any consequences right and that
is changing and i do think this could
change a tide i think if biden wants to
win in 2024 or the dems want to win they
have to we have to have a
obvious victory here we have to put
putin in place um i'm not sure how to do
that and
people
far smarter than i am hopefully working
on this but i think that's the case the
other thing is the saying is dems suck
at war like i generally don't think
we're great at this um and i don't
like and like it's mainly because you
have
twitter savvy
dems saying dumb stuff and i have one my
favorite one of the dumb things i've
heard i mean by the way twitter is ripe
for hot takes right now if you want to
see ridiculous takes this is a good time
for twitter but eric swalwell who i like
we like we kind of had fun with him on
the trail
he floated the idea and i like when
people float ideas out there we float
ideas out but he floated the idea of
kicking
russian
russians in the u.s out of our
universities in retaliation to putin
invading ukraine yeah that's insane
which is and it's that kind of stuff
that like what do republicans do they
grab it they clip it they play it over
and over and dems are more likely to say
that
there's as the party is supposed to be
rational republicans are always doing
dumb [ __ ] i mean russians themselves
aren't for this war russian americans
i'm sure are against this war
um
my favorite eric swalwell story was when
we were backstage your first debate
and you show up in the line like we're
all back there and you show up and you
weren't wearing a tie and he was like oh
you're not wearing a tie
damn man i was gonna do that ah and he
like he was like legit jealous and like
kind of pissed himself i was like hell
yeah uh that's my favorite favorite
swallow eric's a good dude and i like
eric yeah yeah but you know and let me
be the first to say that you know uh bad
twitter take is not a human make so no
it was yeah that's fair but um aware of
that but this was on camera he said it
but but i'm sure that um
so your earlier point about like i i
made a comment a couple of
podcasts ago about how dems i think feel
pressured to be muscular uh about
war because they feel like it's a weak
spot you feel like republicans that was
my point have the hawkish thing and so
democrats
um get painted as doves they feel like
they need to overcompensate someone
interesting the most famous example
being hillary's vote to authorize the
iraq war and then later be like oh
and then obama was like yeah that was a
terrible decision
uh
so
on this one
um
biden
seems relatively
balanced uh you know there is like the
hawkish element what you described is
like look we should be they're fighting
there's a significant amount of me it's
like look like this is the most uh
corrupt unjustified uh like
uh evil
instigation of war against democracy
that i can remember uh and so
if there's anything that you'd be
fighting for like this would be
it
um
are democrats generally
painted into a corner like biden was
meant to restore a degree of competent
leadership and and i would say that
that is the
projection where it seems like he's in
sync with the european leaders that
they're acting
uh with the united front uh that the the
us has been
competent
in this
uh yeah i think it helps them um and i i
feel like
like this portrait is vastly superior to
a trump-led portrait
in another world where trump are
president right now
we all struggle sometimes and it's
particularly true in the winter
sometimes you come back out of that funk
but sometimes you need some serious help
i mean professional help now getting
professional help is easier than ever
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy and i for one am super
pumped to let people know about what
better help can do
for you better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours give it a try and see why
over 2 million people have used better
help online therapy this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp and forward
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com yang that's b e t t e
r h e l p dot com slash yang
get yourself some better help today
you'll be glad you did
[Music]
what are your thoughts on skin in the
game and legacy
in a sense i feel like this drives a lot
of international decisions because it
would if i was in that in those shoes in
a sense
you're joe biden
i don't think this is your like career
defining legacy one you've been there
forever two you were you helped you're
vice president for the first black
president in the united states of
america that's probably the biggest
legacy you're gonna have and the second
one you were the pres you're the
president that defeated donald trump and
was like
institutional sanity right that i think
those legacies will probably outweigh
anything that happens with putin unless
this turns into an all-out world war 3
situation that's my gut i think that's
relatively accurate
if you're trump in this situation
like well i will put an encounter
example out there yeah let's say putin
takes ukraine or
most of ukraine are part of ukraine
and then
uh it emboldens other actors around the
world where everyone's like hey turns
out i can just start taking away
whatever i want yeah and so if biden
were to preside over a complete collapse
of
a sane world order like that might trump
the legacy yeah like that that would be
very very damaging yes it would um
and then i guess my point was on the
flip side trump is
trump's legacy is trump you know what
i'm saying like the trump mindset the
trump way of speaking the trump trump is
the republican party right um
his drain the swamp
kind of like well trump has given rise
to trumpism which will outlive trump
correct yes
so my point was
you know thoughts on the skin in the
game aspect of this so if you're trump
this [ __ ] up this is on your name this
is on you this is your your brand your
your persona trumpism like
essentially on trial and things like
this if you're biden you're probably
like this is an institutional thing so
it's you're getting advice from a bunch
of consultants that
don't have any skin in the game and
their legacy doesn't matter you're
listening to the institutional brain
behind the democratic party who could
care less like when push comes to shove
about this [ __ ] as long as their
family's safe
am i being too cynical there but it was
like it feels like to me like trump
would have more skin in the game to like
like it might be in a bad way it might
be more aggressive so russia
and trump have a certain relationship
here are a couple things i've heard
from the joe biden universe
one thing i've heard is that joe biden
does not want to involve the united
states militarily our sources on the
inside say he's anti
anti
uh what's the word sending american
troops anti-military intervention uh
that's in this situation but that's
anti-intervention to a fault yes um or
not so five oh we're just in our
interventions you could say so so number
one genuinely anti-intervention uh
and
do
other leaders know this
probably probably probably we know it
yeah we know it this is like the dc
insiders know this so you gotta assume
the international leaders know this in
some way yeah the other thing that we're
hearing
is that joe biden wants to run again
um but that there are
misgivings
in the democratic party as to whether
that's a good idea
but obviously joe biden's the single
biggest factor in joe biden already
again
um
and the fact that trump may be the
republican nominee is increasing joe's
desire to run because he feels it's his
job to defeat trump he's done it once
he will do it again
if he kicks putin's ass i think he'll
have a really good shot in 2024.
unfortunately man i think if this
conflict gets resolved uh let's say you
know
early 2022 i think it's a relatively
uh like you're right
like non-factor by the time 24 rolls
around
so anyway the single biggest factor yeah
is going to be what the heck is going on
with our economy which i was just going
to ask you we should so you would yeah
you would talk about the interest rates
in the economy how does this those those
are the political consequences unclear
dems will rally around this if they can
republicans will beat us up on beat them
up on it if they can
what happens to our economy interest
rates inflation what's going to happen
well and i think this is going to play
on the midterms and i'm going to suggest
this is probably the most important
factor in 24. so uh what's going on in
ukraine and this is obviously a
secondary concern to the
uh the logic
you know the the tragic loss of uh of um
life and
stability and people like you know over
a half million people uh they've been
already been uh
um
turned into refugees from their own
country
so
distant second to the human toll
uh prices are likely going to go up as a
result at least in the short term um
even though sanctions have not been
applied directly to uh the energy sector
which is russia's biggest
export the rest of it right
but even the sanctions that have already
been put in place will
spur increased inflation and uh in the
u.s or global or both here and globally
both here and globally um so one of the
the
wilder uh facets was that
and this is a sign of where we are in
you know in america today
is that there was a market rally because
the expectations were that
uh interest rates will remain low longer
[Music]
because of instability
so
inflation
is at
you know multi-year multi-decade highs
it's imposing a lot of pain on a lot of
people
this conflict is going to make it worse
um i'm not sure if most people are going
to quote unquote blame
um
uh
buying the democrats for that because in
this one any additional inflation it's
like obviously you know this is on putin
but a lot of americans just
see what they they're paying when they
buy gas they go buy groceries the
economy's not good it hurts sitting
president every time yeah
and
uh there there's actually a discussion
around joe's framing so here's what's
happening and i find this very agitating
is that um every
president essentially just talks about
like how good the economy is
um
and there are things you can point to
right now that suggest it is a good
economy um but there are so many metrics
that don't mean anything you could
probably point to but anything at any
time saying things are good but there
are a whole lot of americans who uh
would completely disagree with any
positive evaluation in the economy
and i think that's going to carry
through this year i think it's going to
to play out in the midterms and then the
question is whether things are um
hunky-dory by 24
now now the the
problem for
us all really
is that we've had this extended period
of artificially low interest rates um
that have spurred
speculative bubbles in a lot of things
and so that there's an investor
that um said to me look like here's the
math and it's problematic is that if you
have interest rates go up by a certain
amount um and you owe
you know whatever it is 130 of gdp or
whatever we owe um then the amount
you're paying to service the national
debt shoots up
to a significant portion of the federal
budget
but maybe equally disconcertingly
a lot of the
stock market valuations are based upon
very very low interest rates because you
can project out a certain value in x
years and because the interest rate is
low then you can justify a very high
valuation but if the interest rate goes
up and you apply that interest rate uh
across multiple years then this
valuation no longer makes sense and then
the valuations have to come down it's
crazy how interconnected all this stuff
is yeah so uh so
the single biggest driver right now of
these valuations is what's going to
happen with interest rates there are
certain
uh fed
hikes that are priced in
uh anything that affects those hikes
ends up being like a uh you know frankly
like you know uh mini correction in the
stock market like that the next day
we're expecting an interest rate hike to
fight inflation is that where you but
you're saying this will
how will this affect it yeah the
expectation was that there would be
something like you know six uh quarter
point hikes over the the next 12 months
and that stuff's more or less priced in
and that's necessary to combat inflation
that's at seven and a half percent
annualized or or whatnot um so now the
the tough part is that inflation's going
to go up
um you may have to rise and raise the
rates even higher but strangely enough
that the fed is signaling or at least
the market is expecting the fed to say
look we're not going to raise interest
rates because we don't want to uh
spook the markets or like you know uh
the the
um because of global instability
essentially so that there is this
massive reckoning that's coming down the
pike that no one knows how it's going to
be resolved when there are a number of
interconnected variables number one the
rate of inflation painfully high number
two
uh national debt um
much higher than that it's banned and uh
up and up and then uh stock market
valuations that are reliant upon low
interest rates
then and then interest rates that have
been kept aberrantly low
artificially low
so
i've talked to a number of very very
experienced investors including david
rubenstein on the podcast where he
looked up and said well there are only a
few ways out of this and what he joked
about but it was accurate he said that
when he left office under the carter
administration
inflation was at 15 so no one wants it
back
but
back then
uh the national debt was something like
30 percent of gdp instead of 130 oh
interesting so that if you had
higher interest rates it doesn't
increase your costs uh as much
um
so that there are
just a lot of people have looked at this
and said hey look like this math doesn't
add up
uh you know one one person who said this
to me when i had dinner with him uh you
know like a week or so ago tom steyer
who's obviously you know hyper
experienced investor and he looked at
this and said like hey you know like
these numbers
are
going to have to
uh correct in one way or another and the
magnitude of the correction
is
uh almost
unthinkably vast i've been there have
been some
investment experts who've gone to the
press and saying we're headed for a big
correction that no one's really fully
understood the logic here sound like we
have a bit of an unsustainable situation
going on and geopolitical factors that
are driving them the wrong way right i
i will say this if what you're talking
about actually happens you have a big
market correction and that sort of thing
it doesn't matter what happens in russia
or these culture issues like the dems or
toast with a bad economy you know um
it's usually
it's it's you you know it's the economy
stupid or whatever the
you know famous adages um oh so this is
the great fear and i unfortunately do
send some parallels yeah uh is that uh
joe biden will be stuck with a jimmy
carter-esque
situation
um the the issue so there's a fed chair
paul volcker under jimmy carter who just
turned the screws and said we're going
to whip inflation it was a whip
inflation now win everyone distributed
win buttons and the way they whipped
inflation was they just freaking turned
those interest rates up
so high
that that you had uh double digit
unemployment and uh recession
um and that got carter out of office
essentially he was a one term where he
lost to reagan yeah um so joe biden has
inherited a similar situation uh but the
variables are significantly worse yep
um
[Music]
so if you believe in the laws of
economic physics
there would have to be some
draconian measures but if
if the fed chair today were to do what
volker did then it would be completely
unacceptable
and the damage would be far worse
because
the um the debt is so much higher
well
hopefully
i don't know we've had a number of
conversations on this podcast in
particular and personally that economic
physics
have either been
ignored either they either don't matter
anymore or
we've been ignoring them forever and
they're going to come home to roost at
some point but unclear when and how yeah
and how yeah uh
but
i don't know man um i do think
it sounds like the russia ukraine
conflict will have various political
consequences whether it's the war itself
or the economic impacts
and so the economic impact i want to be
clear
um uh it's it's uncle it's not it's you
know
not clear how significant it's going to
be but it's not going to be good
it's going to hurt people [ __ ] it's
going to hurt people at the gas station
it's going to hurt people
um
in their pocketbook you know like that
like that's very very certain
can biden do anything to prevent that
end this conflict is well one thing they
just did as like a tiny example of
something you might want to do is they
just release 60 million barrels from the
the national oil reserve got it um so
they're they're taking reasons supply of
oil to bring the price down they're
taking some steps they're like all right
let's
let's start these are the people i pray
for you know the
theoretically very smart people the
decisions of very few impacting the
lives of many
[Music]
i have run small businesses and bigger
businesses for a couple decades now and
the big lesson is that you have to use
your time effectively you know what's
not an effective use of your time
waiting in the post office you can do
better than that and with stamps.com you
can skip that trip and focus on the
things your business actually needs to
grow
yep stamps.com will let you print
postage right from your computer save
you money
more importantly it will save you time
because time is where it's at stop
overpaying for shipping with stamps.com
sign up with promo code yang for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial free postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
page and enter code yang give yourself
your time back never wait in line at a
post office again stamps.com
enter code yang
[Music]
and i do think
the united states has done it
i'd argue a really good job or a decent
job of like maintaining the money supply
and balancing the interest rates since
late 80s and 90s right i mean there's
some there's some ups and downs but um
like i would disagree but continue
i look we're not japan right like you
know like even like as bad as 2008 was
like we got out of it right as bad as
the early late 90s where we got out of
there so so here is the like the my take
on it is that um so there are these
massive imbalances leading up to 2008
and then 2008 there should have been
this reckoning that was absent
and that reckoning should have been
uh political which uh it should have
been criminal
it should have been civil and then it
should have been economic
um i agree with that but the excess was
too much but we live in a time when no
one wanted to pay the price and so they
just said hey what's that like bank
mortgage-backed securities it's cool
here your bonuses no one go to jail um
hey what's that like you know stock
market cap problematic here's hundreds
of billions of dollars recap what's that
uh you know you need interest rates to
be low to like kind of keep the party
going sure
uh and and we've done that i still can't
believe that that was 14 years ago
and you've essentially had
a liquidity fueled like quasi
expansion ever since like we ordinarily
you have a recession every eight years
or so
and we're in year 14 of this mega cycle
that's fueled by just like massive
liquidity uh and
it's it's unclear how this ends but you
know like the david rubinsteins and the
tom steyers look at this and are like
because they they're frankly kind of
older like you know rubenstein's in the
70s tom you know is in i like i don't
know 50s or 60s so they're like hey
we've kind of seen this movie um and
this is like a mega sized version of
that movie so just because there hasn't
been a reckoning yet
uh like it's been building and even the
2008 stuff was built upon
um in my view like you know like not
great
uh governance and monetary policy
leading up to that
oh and awful yeah awful so so if you
back date this
like i i think we're looking at uh
something last legal things like that
yeah exactly like that you know like the
the old days when you were like well we
can't have an investment bank in a
commercial bank in the same room and
they're like no you can do it yeah that
was good thank you bill yes so right it
was from that era of deregulation so
you're looking at uh approximately like
a 26-year period of excess that's just
getting built and built and it's kicking
the can down the road our politicians
have been a huge part of it because
they've been like what you know fiscal
responsibility pasha like you know like
republicans are in power they're like
cut taxes
uh you know democrats in power they were
like well you know like
let's uh add on some new stuff and like
not actually look at any of the stuff
that that currently is going out um so i
i talk to people and it's funny because
i have a fairly
let's say you know ambitious view on
like what we can do societally
like which i still hold but there are a
lot of people who are
in this investor class who are
deeply concerned
about the fact that we have this
uh essentially mega bubble that's been
building up over not years but decades
the question is how much of these
economic physics you're talking about
have as i said before have they changed
are they fundamentally different and
this is like the super money you're
talking about we're like you know what
this is what the web 3 and crypto
community argues all the times that
money you made it up right you're just
backing it by the faith in the united
states so we left the gold standard a
long time ago yeah we can build
something that everybody else trusts
which is going to be more trustworthy
because it's going to be math and
[ __ ] numbers and science and
algorithms and transparent um
and
so i mean if that's the argument then we
can probably do no wrong i don't know um
and i guess that's what the investors
are like this doesn't seem like it's
adding up but you know what they've been
saying that
for a while i don't know if that's good
or i mean it's probably not a good thing
but maybe it's a new normal
i'm probably wrong in that it's probably
just gonna blow up my face and then you
know re-record and clip this podcast
back i don't know i mean it's true well
you know i mean we're living in
unprecedented times uh
and i mean it's also true that
um the us has a global reserve currency
and that may suspend the laws of uh
physics in a particular way it
definitely warps them
right um
yeah and there's no real threat to the
u.s dollar supremacy and there's a
threat militarily like who collects our
debts if we default
there's a like this is the other piece
of this puzzle i think a lot like
back in the day if something you owe
them money
you don't get it what does a mom do they
[ __ ] kill you like you if you storm
the castle right whatever it is you go
to war the issue in this case is that
you know we're like continuously
financing based on debt so even though
people were like hey i'm going to stop
buying your net then what are we there's
like there's micro effects and my point
was like the us defaults they never will
or if they you know there's
i mean heck we might default for
political stupidity yeah we're
definitely at some point we'll default
on something we've done haven't we done
it before we fade we failed to uh
well there's the entire debt ceiling yes
we've been suspension
oh my god this is political theater
they're just bored they're looking for
another conflict um
this is our world this is a little
depressing what's getting you excited
this week man
uh
well this week we're celebrating the
successful launch of lobby threes
three man
for those of you don't care about crypto
we're sorry for plugging it but i do
think
it is a very
worthwhile and it's a very wholesome
endeavor i mean we're trying to take
some of the resources
that have been
uh generated over this past period of
time and improve people's lives in the
real world and then make it the case
that we should be doing more of this and
by the way
you know
this can help a lot of people in
different contexts uh i i'm
super excited about some of the things
going on with the forward party we have
some great stuff uh in the pipe
um so so that makes me happy yup all the
time i you know i i will say first thank
you to everyone who listens and supports
generally uh uh extra thank you to folks
who decided to support
forward because
uh october we launch
and
you know i'm like a fairly
uh confident resolute guy so i'm like
all right let's do this thing okay um
but there is like a significant part of
you that's like oh i hope people hope
this goes well i hope our people are
like are
excited about it can see it yeah uh and
understand the need
um and so the fact that now the forward
party is this thriving organization with
volunteers in states around the country
and
uh you know financial resources to be
able to
actually operate and all these things i
mean it's really
special and wonderful and i'm so
grateful and so if if you're listening
to this and you're
like a donor or supporter or volunteer
like thank you from the bottom of my
heart because we have a very important
case to make
to the american people in the world
about what the future can be more people
are waking up every day to the fact that
this system as it stands is totally
dysfunctional and polarizing uh and the
answer is not going to come from within
the uh we were doing a
twitter spaces
on or maybe it was in our discord on on
lobby three and
someone said something really
interesting is that well andrea i love
what you're doing but like i
i don't i'm worried that you're going to
distract from forward or i want you know
i don't want you to i hope you haven't
given up on forward and i to me my
takeaway is like um
i wanted to clarify this but
forward if it's successful
has to be bigger than you it can't be an
andrew yang thing it has to be
a
thriving and it's happening in that
direction and it's going that way and
that's the point and
i think it either has to do one of two
things you know it needs to become
a
effective competitive third-party option
which i think that's where it's headed
or and they're not mutually exclusive
but the second one it needs to trail
blaze
for other parties to get started as well
um where i think you then start about a
more dynamic diverse democracy yeah well
in order for new entrants to emerge you
have to change the mechanics but i agree
with you that
what we're doing with lobby three
and the forward party very much are
complementary mutually beneficial i mean
some of the people that have been most
excited about forward party have
actually been
uh
like folks from the web 3 community oh
yeah there's a limit for sure yeah
there's those principles are very
aligned and then the principle of
anything you've done like the core
hasn't changed much i mean the press
will freak out about everything else but
yeah it's so i i'm i'm super pumped
about yeah how things are going and you
know i don't take it for granted for one
second i mean it really is remarkable so
when when forward launched in october
like i hit the trail was doing book
events around the country um you know
one of those is now available on
fordparty.com that you can just watch
the video and if you
uh make a small donation
um and uh
during that time i was hopeful that it's
like okay hopefully people see what i'm
doing and and we'll get behind it
and now we are
you know what
four months later or something like that
and like the ground's already firm
beneath our feet like it it's
awesome and we're just gonna keep on
growing it's a herculean task so that
that does make me excited last night
makes me excited batman comes out
this weekend
god i hope it's good
i hope it's good man robert pattinson
don't let me down
are you a fan of his from twilight or
harry potter um or something else
because he's done a lot of indie stuff i
love tim in what's the movie where he's
like getting chased i can't remember but
he's like in the streets like he's got
like it's like a gun violence street
violence movie he's really good it's
called running something
um
thank you i'm a fan i love that movie
good time i actually thought he was
great in that and then he's also james
going to know this one too he's also in
a movie i think with william defoe in
black and white called the lighthouse
that's right yep
nailed it uh our producer's like
very
movie buff sounds like or lame he just
like knows a lot about movies and
directors and things like that so thank
you james um
he's got a wide range of talent in my
opinion and we uh we did not meet him
but we shared like a waiting room with
him uh on the presidential as he was on
npr at the same time you were we didn't
recognize him until he was like leaving
like i was
that was batman twilight that was bruce
wayne he didn't say batman he was back
that was uh edward cullen that's his
name from twilight it was bruce wayne
i hope he's good he's a talent actor i
hope the movie's good because i was such
i'm christopher nolan's still my
favorite director and so i've been
waiting for someone to do batman well
again
um
and so i hope this is a crack at it the
critics somewhat like it daily mail
ripped it apart
tbd i'm optimistic i like matt reeves
work i think pattinson is a very
talented actor yeah yeah uh yeah i mean
i feel like the last big movie was
uh spider-man no way home which was
awesome which was awesome
this is a different theme it's very very
different
at the end all three batmen show up no
spoiler alert oh [ __ ] just kidding
that's actually at your time like five
batman hang on
ben affleck
christian bale who was before that
i remember the old ones like kilmer but
of alcohol george clooney
and keaton michael keaton it's five so
people are totally going to omit clooney
from this list because he only showed up
once and no idea once i did not do well
you know be cool the villains were still
great though schwarzeneggers mr freeze
and danny devito as penguin like come on
jim carrey as the riddler like i'm not
saying the movies were that great but
just like
the vibe cast i thought was pretty cool
jack nicholson as the joker like come on
these are like very iconic castings but
it was different type of
uh
different type of movie it was a little
more a little more comic booky if you
will james is our producer is listening
this is probably like rolling he wants
to throw up in his mouth about our
ineffective movie takes but you know
you're all here for it if you're still
listening we love you for listening to
that take care of yourself out there uh
to the extent that the news is
getting to you mentally feel free to
take a break from it feel free to you
know just take a walk outside
just remember to control the things you
can control do the things you can do
don't imagine that the weight of the
world is on your shoulders because the
most important thing you can do
is feel good uh take care of yourself
that's going to make you more able to
take care of the people around you and
and do the things that
you need to do
we're back monday and then with ramesh
and andrew and i back on thursday see
you then
[Music]
you